bon d'abord jean luc mélenchon et moi on
a une relation qui vient de très loin
moi je fais partie de la très longue
marche puisque ça fait 30 ans que aux
militants semblent donc fausse figurait
qu'au départ on était voilà une
quinzaine dans une pizzeria
quand on décide de faire un des clubs
politiques et finalement de construire
ce courant et puis aussi cette cette
candidature parce qu'en définitive c'est
quand même devenu assez vite l'idée que
tu puisses être candidat à la présidence
de la république parce que c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde sur ses 30 ans je pense
que les gens à la maison ont du mal à
s'imaginer que ce petit groupe
du départ arrive à faire en 2017 20% des
voix aux élections hélas en 2022 je suis
sûr que c'est la bonne
vous pensez que c'est la bonne oui j'en
suis sûr jenson certaine et je trouve
qu'elle a à l'amci me ci c'est la bonne
alors aujourd'hui qu'une petite question
est ce que ce sera votre garde des
sceaux
d'ordonner chaud
c'est quand même mon métier je suis
avocat d'une compétence en la matière
mais autant lui que le sait très bien
que moi j'ai toujours aspiré à m'occuper
d'assemblée concerné lui aller à
l'assemblée contre atlanta et et elle l
est l achat depuis le début parce que
c'est la personne qui a porté dans notre
mouvement depuis le plus longtemps des
fois un peu rabâcher l'idée et puis qui
a aidé à la compléter ses dires la sq au
début une assemblée constituante ça
paraissait munichois on comprend pas bon
tout le monde comprend pas et puis elle
a commencé à amener des choses quand
même le droit de le pouvoir de le
référendum révocatoire c'est-à-dire un
élu dont vous n'êtes pas content vous
pouvez le virer à condition évidemment
de réunir un certain nombre de
signatures et c est dans son pays
d'origine il ya eu une élection
constituante donc elle et moi on a été
heureux comme c'est pas possible parce
qu'on aurait lieu des comptes avec les
pinochetiste 1 et puis parce que le
peuple le peuple chilien revenait à
s'occuper de ses affaires c'est magique
on a des passions communes des passions
politiques mais des passions communes
alors raquel oui c'est d'ailleurs le
fait que reçoit
alors toi tu n'es pas immigré au sens où
tu as des français tu le disais tout à
l'heure mais quand même arrivé voilà sur
ton bateau est arrivée en france à onze
ans j'avais 10 ans j'allais avoir 12 ans
ouais c'est ça ouais mais j'étais un
petit français de tanger ils parlaient
espagnol et un peu l'arabe j'avais tout
sur les pièges à oiseaux respect pas
mais à l'époque on parlait que de ça et
moi j'avais 14 ans quand je suis arrivé
en france c'était en septembre 88 et
rapidement j'ai commencé à militer dans
les mouvements lycéens et ensuite je
suis arrivée à la fac et j'ai rencontré
jean luc mélenchon et je l'écoutais
parler notamment de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme de l'histoire de la
révolution française
de la patrie républicaine des français
qui était un vocabulaire que je trouvais
très fort qui me parlait beaucoup et moi
à cette époque là je pensais que tous
les français pensaient comme ça je
pensais que ça ne pouvait pas exister en
français qui ne soit pas amoureux de la
révolution française qui soit pas
passionnément d'accord avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen parce que moi j'étais immigrés
je me disais mais ces trois que c'est
génial ce qu'ils ont inventé les
français mais dis moi j'ai trop envie
d'elle dans son groupe qui a inventé ça
donc c'était trop facile et ça donnait
envie d'être français et d'aimer la
france dé mêlée français et ça pour ça
je vais te dire merci à eux
[Applaudissements]